[Music]
at sunset
on thursday the 7th of july the squadron
was according to observation about 40
miles from cape negatsuwo
or itzu as it is otherwise called the
heads of the ships
were put offshore from midnight until
four o'clock next morning
when the first sight of japan was
obtained from the masthead
although the morning was fine the
atmosphere was so
hazy that there was but an indistinct
view of the outline of the precipitous
coast
through the mist however the bold
promontory of idzu
could be seen rising loftily from the
sea
and stretching back on a crowd of
mountainous elevations
the course of the squadron was now
pointed directly
to the entrance of the bay of yedo
[Music]
the commodore had determined to push his
way as near as possible to yeto
the capital situated at the head of the
bay of the same name
so he boldly steamed where steemer had
never
ventured before and was soon plowing the
remote waters of japan
and looking with eager interest upon the
novel scene
which surrounded him
as the ships closed in with the land and
as the fog
occasionally lifted a glance was here
and there
caught of the neighboring shores that
were observed to rise in
precipitous bluffs which connected
landward with undulating hills
the shores of the bay particularly on
the western side
were populous with a succession of towns
and villages
picturesquely grouped in groves of pines
and other trees
the rising ground which came down from
the mountainous interior
abruptly terminated at the water's edge
in precipitous headlands
and was crowned with white forts more
formidable in appearance than in reality
the bay was busy with trading junks
sailing up and down with their broad
sails or putting in here and there at
the various ports
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so of course as we know coco is the
brains behind the channel
after watching all of magellan's
documentaries uh coco
can you tell us your theory about the
construction of the pyramids please
ah ah okay fair enough
i forgot the coco specialities
pre-dynastic chinese history
and that's why her and my recommendation
is mysteries of
china which tells the story of the
terracotta warriors and the very first
emperor in style for those that don't
know magellan is like a netflix for
documentaries
it has the widest range of historical
content available anywhere along with
lots of other genres
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers
thanks
the fleet of japanese boats supposed to
be government vessels
pulled out into the stream with the
apparent purpose of arresting the
progress
of the squadron the steamers however
passed them contemptuously by
and as they moved along rapidly on their
course at the rate of
eight or nine knots an hour with all
their sails furled
the japanese were soon left behind
and in a state evidently of much
amazement at the sight of the first
vessels they had ever beheld
impelled by steam
as the day advanced the sun came out
dispelling the mist which had gathered
over the land and revealing a wide
prospect
of the distant country mount
fuji was now seen rising to an immense
height with its cone-like summit covered
with snow which glistened brightly
in the sun
the ships as they approached their
anchorage continued sounding at every
turn of the steam as wheels
and they moved on slowly and cautiously
until they reached a part of the bay
of the city of uraga on the western side
the anchors were now let go and the
squadron was securely moored in japanese
waters
within a nearer distance of the capital
of yedo than any
foreign vessel had ever ventured
as the ships brought to commanding with
their guns
the town of uraga and the battery upon
its promontory
two guns were fired from the neighboring
forts and rockets were discharged into
the air
for the purpose probably of signalizing
the authorities
at the capitol
an immense fleet of government boats
each distinguished by a white flag at
the stern
with a black central stripe and a tassel
at the bow
came in accordance with the usual
practice in japanese waters
hovering about the squadron the
commodore had issued orders that no one
from the shore
should be allowed to board either of his
vessels
except his own flagship
some of the boats however attempted to
get alongside the saratoga
and the crews clung to the chains until
they were repelled
with considerable violence
one of the japanese boats was allowed to
come alongside the susquehanna
and everyone on board of the steamer was
struck with the resemblance of her build
as well as of the others to that of the
famous yacht
america she was trimly built
of pine wood apparently without a touch
of paint
and was propelled over the water with
great swiftness
by a numerous crew of boatmen who
standing to their oars at the stern
skulled instead of rowing the boat the
men
were naked with the exception of a cloth
around their loins
and were wonderfully stalwart and active
fellows
two persons armed each with a couple of
swords a japanese mark of official rank
stood toward the boughs and were
evidently
men of authority as the boat reached the
side of the steamer
one of these dignitaries held up a
scroll
which turned out to be a document in the
french and dutch
languages ordering off the ships and
forbidding them
to anchor at their peril
no notice was taken of this very
preemptory summons
and the officer on the deck of the
commodore ship refused
positively to touch the paper
this was reported to the commodore who
kept secluded in his cabin
and he sent word that no one but a
dignitary of the highest rank
would be received the chinese
interpreter
attached to the squadron tried to make
this understood to the japanese
but as there seemed some difficulty one
of the two functionaries in the boat
who was the chief spokesman cried out in
very good english
i can speak dutch the dutch interpreter
was then summoned in the emergency and
the parlay
ensued in the course of which it was
learnt that the two officials
alongside were nagasima zabaraskay
the vice governor of uraga and hori
tetsunosuke
an interpreter as they insisted that
they were the proper persons with whom
to confer
they were admitted on board the japanese
were now told
that the commodore bore a letter to the
emperor
from the president of the united states
which he was prepared to deliver so soon
as a proper person
was appointed to receive it to this they
replied that nagasaki
in the island of kyusu was the only
place where
any such communication could be received
and that the ships must proceed there
immediately
this being reported to the commodore he
sent back an answer
declaring that he would not go to
nagasaki
and moreover if the authorities did not
remove their boats which were thronging
about the ships
he would disperse them by force
this last piece of intelligence produced
a very prompt effect
for the vice governor of uraga rose
hurriedly on learning it
and going to the gangway beckoned the
guard boats away
in reference to the reception of the
president's letter the japanese
dignitary said he had
nothing more to say but that another
personage of
higher rank would come next morning and
confer with the commodore about it
the japanese now took their departure
the presence of the americans in the bay
of yedo was evidently exciting a very
lively apprehension among those on shore
for guns were frequently
firing signal rockets shooting up into
the air soldiers parading about the
batteries on the various headlands
and at night bells were tiling and
beacon fires were blazing
and illuminating the long extent of
shore
[Music]
in accordance with the vice governor's
promise his superior
the governor of uraga visited the
susquehanna the next day
notwithstanding the former gentleman had
said at first that he himself was the
proper person
and that it was against the laws of
japan for the latter
to board a foreign ship but this kind of
deception is a recognized element of
japanese diplomacy
and lying is an established function of
japanese official duties and the
commodore regulated his conduct
accordingly the governor who sent in his
name upon his gigantic red card as
kayaman yazaimon was a more imposing
personage than his vice governor
and was robed in character with his
greater pretensions
he wore the usual japanese loose gown
something like a clerical robe
which in this case was a rich silk
embroidered with a pattern of
peacock feathers in the sash which
girded his waist
with thrust the two swords of dignity
and on his head
was a lacquered cap like a reversed
basin
reminding one of don quixote's helmet of
mambrino
when he uncovered the usual manner of
dressing the hair was disclosed
in which the head is shaved from the
forehead far back
izemon was admitted to an interview not
however with a commodore
who still preserved his dignified
reserve
but with one of the captains in the
course of which he was told very much
the same things that were told to his
predecessor he finding that the
commodore was resolute in his
declaration that he would not
go to nagasaki promised to refer the
subject to the imperial government
nagasaki it will be recollected is the
place where the dutch factory is
established
and where the japanese desire to confine
all their relationships with foreigners
under the same degrading restrictions to
those to which the hollanders have
for the sake of a little trade so long
and so
discreditably submitted
the commodore had sent out a number of
boats well armed to survey the bay
and as they proceeded with their work
troops of japanese
soldiers thronged the shores and the
batteries
while fleets of government boats with
armed men under the command of
military officers pushed out into the
stream
with the apparent purpose of
intercepting the surveyors
the american lieutenant who led the
survey party
ordered his men to rest upon their oars
a while and to adjust the caps to their
pistols
that they might be prepared for what
appeared to be the imminent prospect
of a collision the japanese however
observing the resolute attitude of the
strangers
sculled their trim boats fast away and
the americans were left
undisturbed in their labors
izemon having observed the survey boats
busy in the bay
expressed great anxiety and declared
that it was against
the japanese laws to which he was
answered that the american laws
commanded
and that the americans were as much
bound to obey the latter as his
countrymen
were the former the commodore had
everything in battle array in case of a
rupture
he had cleared the decks placed his guns
in position
and shot at them and had done all that
was usual
before meeting an enemy
not that the commodore anticipated
actual hostilities
but that he was resolved to be on the
alert in case of an emergency
the japanese on their part were no less
engaged in busy preparations
furbishing up their forts and extending
long stretches of black canvas to either
side
with the view of giving them a more
formidable aspect
not conscious apparently that the
telescopes from the ship's decks
disclosed all their sham contrivances
for effect
after the most provoking and tedious
negotiation with the government of uraga
who almost daily visited the susquehanna
and offered every
obstacle in his power to the commodore's
resolute determination to be received by
a proper personage to whom he might
deliver the president's
letter it was at last reluctantly
decided by the government of japan
that the commodore's wish should be
complied with
[Music]